I like this
is
[Music]
Shakira isn't feeling so romantic on
Valentine's Day as she seemingly Shades
her ex Gerard Pique it's been quite a
journey this is the cryptic video the
singer shared on v-day lip syncing along
to scissors Kill Bill you know a song
about a scorned woman getting revenge on
her ex
[Music]
sometimes the message definitely you
have to walk through whatever's
happening yeah and Shakira really
commits mop and all as she sings her
heart out
[Music]
alone
but the Grammy winner is no stranger to
Throwing Shade with music I want to
share with my fans and I want them to
like it in bizarrep music session number
53 a surprise track the singer dropped
last month she slams the former Soccer
Pro and his new girlfriend 23 year old
Clara Chia Marty
those lyrics You traded a Ferrari for a
twingo you traded a Rolex for Ocasio
then their Shakira's 2022 hit te
felicito with Raul Alejandro which
resurfaced last month with fans noticing
some details they didn't see before
[Music]
so why the head in the fridge well the
singer reportedly learned her man was
unfaithful after she noticed her Jam
Supply had gone down and allegedly
Shakira is the only person in her family
who likes Jam which leads to the
specular nation of who was eating it
there's a moment in the video where you
go to the fridge and you're not going to
the fridge for milk tell me about that
what's going on to find out the truth so
I go to the refrigerator and when I find
Raul Hunter's head
which is pretty scary I guess that it
happens to all of us once in a while you
know
us women
that you think that you're in a real
relationship and it's not as real as it
seems since then Gerard's gone Instagram
official with Clara and he actually
spoke about Shakira in a recent
interview with tick tocker John Nellis
the first time since their breakup I
asked PK who the most famous person in
his contacts was both football and
non-football the answer wasn't what I
expected I would say
Shakira maybe it was my Farmer yeah my
my partner
could be one if it's not related to
football
yeah seemingly no bad blood on Gerard's
end but Shakira seems she's still
feeling some type of way
[Music]
s